So here's what you're going to do, Edward. I would make sure to do everything you can,
get this sucker ranked, manage those expectations, and get ready to get that business owner into a
sixth month to a year contract as soon as possible. What I would do is after month two,
I would start, I would figure out maybe we need to bump up the ads a little bit.
Maybe we need to like check in extra, whatever, because I know that between month two and three
is when I need to renew. And if you don't renew for at least six months in October,
there's a good chance they're going to cancel. If you go to a month to month,
by December things slow down and it's Christmas and all these different things,
it's going to be a problem. So what I would do is I would crush it for this person in both areas.
In between months two and three, I would really up my game so that you can get those
re-signs into the six month a year contracts. And then you could kind of take a little bit
of a deep breath and go back to your strategy. But from experience, that's what I would do.
Also a friendly reminder, guys, I would not be recommending a six month contract right now.
August, September, October, November, December, January, that's going to put you in a really
weird spot. You're going to have a contract ending at the end of Christmas. And unless you're in the
snow removal niche and you're in a city that has snow year round, which I don't know if there are
any, it's going to be a problem. So guys, I know the training says six month contracts,
but we have to also use our head. Right now, I would do what Edward is doing. I would either
do a three month or I'd do a nine month. I would definitely push for the nine month before the
three month. But keep in mind, if you do a six month, the contract's going to end in the middle
of the freaking winter and it's going to be a problem. It's really hard to renew contracts,
relatively speaking, in the middle of the winter.